worry about that pick and roll up top at
the side are you gonna switch or not
switch show and return we'll see
[Applause]
Tyler Dorsey he's got no shot
[Music]
dad's got it locked on automatic now
Kevin is 3 for 3 there step coming back
down the rebound
[Applause]
that was all the curried offensive
rebound
yes it is you that with George Josh to
cook the bread
[Applause]
his perfect 5
the ball back
since missing the three they're gonna
take Cupid on
it's the easiest to come on step bottom
again
phase one half court two seconds left
Durant's got the seal Durant catches
[Applause]
my dream on the early seal by KD
[Music]
[Applause]
disjunction
[Applause]
ran for the baseline stones you have to
miss an aim of eight
[Applause]
for three perfect he's at an eighth of
nine game in his career
how about nine of nine tonight clear out
just get the heck out of the way
signs about flow this is sighs on sighs
hey Dee I'm a predict Durant will not
take a shot for us the game he continues
the best shooting night of his career
[Music]
Jadey
this incredible night I just figured it
out he knows he's not gonna miss